hi Emily how are you I'm good I'm very
happy to see you um you know let's first
explain where you are are you outside of
London somewhere are you in a rural area
in England I'm in a rural area in
England yes okay I like that you're
saying that as if you really don't want
me to know exactly where you are because
you think I'm creepy
that's the way you said that in the
continental England which includes
Scotland okay it was the way you phrase
the question you said it like it was
slightly sort of sinister where I might
be that's I think that's just how I come
across to women and I apologize bath
outside bath okay is that is that from
Chaucer I don't they on their way to
bath or they're coming back from Africa
be the wife of thought there's a wife
okay
I knew I knew something was going on
with bath there was a historical
reference that I had to make let me I
thank you that's the reason I did it I
want to ask you first of all I want to
point out that I did an interview with
someone on a podcast recently who was in
England and I could see them it was a
zoom call and we were chatting and it
was in the morning for me and it went
early in the in the in the zoom call
this woman picked up a glass of wine and
took a big and I thought oh my god she's
an alcoholic
I forgot that she lists it's night time
for you no I'm not gonna show you what
I've got beneath the the computer screen
but there's the hope there's a bar
basically at my feet well feel free to
drink I want everyone to be relaxed
especially you and and so just you know
it's fine it's fine if you drink because
I will tell all my viewers that you are
in London and it's it's the drinking
hour where you
your drink yes exactly exactly don't
tell them I'm actually in Palm Springs
and thank you
and that you have a ribbed Palm Springs
eight o'clock a.m. and everyone's gonna
think you have a big problem